Tim let's start things off with one of
our favorite questions to ask our guests
what are your thoughts on the direction
of our world you know this is really a
great question because over over the
last 50 years if you just watch the news
you think the sky is falling you think
the world is coming to an end but over
the last 50 years
think of how our world has what's
transpired people talk about all the
murders and murder rate is so far down
if people talk about oh we're you know
we're not moving progress along or
whatever the difference between how we
live now and how we live 50 years ago is
extraordinary I mean a lot of people
didn't have still don't but still
running water electricity since then
things like the computer the the smart
phone uber you know some extraordinary
things have happened we've been able to
communicate across around the world so
if you ask me what I think is gonna be
happening moving forward I think we're
gonna we're gonna have an acceleration
of progress amazing change is gonna
happen and I think we're gonna see the
decentralization of everything of the
world I think the world's going to go
from tribal we were all tribal because
we were sort of protecting our things in
our space and now we're gonna go global
because the the tribes don't matter
anymore the geographic borders matter
much less than they ever did before and
over time I think governments are going
to have to compete a cross border the
way Estonia has already started to do so
this is going to be a really interesting
time I think we're going to go through
this amazing there's gonna be an amazing
leap forward for Humanity it's gonna go
from this this world where we really
cared about what the borders were and
what our government said to where we're
starting to start thinking about how are
we going to a approach humanity and how
how are all of us going to be doing
flying through the
in this beautiful pearl we live on